all right time now for our daily polling
pit stop all about the conservative
leadership race let's bring in the
director and co-founder of delta poll
that's joe twyman for more on this joe
good to have you with us as always all
right let's start with the latest poll
from redfield and wilton strategies this
is all about um how the race is being
viewed in the red wall and whether or
not actually more broadly the government
is taking the right decisions to deal
with the cost of living crisis
yes that's right and what we're seeing
in this poll is really a reflection of
the national picture and also a
reflection of the picture we've seen in
the polling now for some months
of course the conservative leadership
election is not among the uh the general
public it's among the conservative
mahati members but certainly among the
general public and among the red wall we
see that the labour are consistently
ahead in the polls in this recent most
recent poll of the red wall later have a
15 lead
and it emphasizes the difficulty that
the conservative party are in at the
moment now of course once the new leader
is in place uh there is potential for
change and certainly the conservative
party will hope for change because on
these figures and many others that that
we've seen over recent weeks and months
the conservatives are not in the kind of
position that will
lead their leader whoever that is to
stay in downing street come the next
general election so things have to uh
things have to change but what is also
clear in this polling and many other
polls that have taken place is that the
cost of living crisis is hugely
important now this dates back back to
all the way back to february of this
year when the cost of living crisis
emerged as the most important issue
facing the country and the most
important issue facing people and their
families and as time has gone on concern
for that has increased in this most
recent poll three quarters of people
said that they didn't think the
government had the uh
the right solutions to the cost of
living crisis and again this is
something that uh that has been
consistent and
the
conservative party candidates at the
moment are playing very much to the
selectorate that uh that will be voting
for them the conservative party members
but their response is most notably
saying oh well no handouts uh we've
heard that language for uh
for dealing with the crisis that won't
necessarily play well with the general
public come the winter as fuel payments
rise and as fuel use increases and also
it won't play well with with these key
marginal constituencies not just in the
red wall of course but in all of those
constituencies gained by the
conservatives the last election that
they'll need to hold on to if they're
going to maintain their majority yeah
joe talk to us about this slogan that's
used by the conservative party about
leveling up um red wall voters have been
asked about that and their feelings
around this idea and of course is the
idea that you'll uh
regenerate some of the poorest parts of
the country uh what are they saying
about the way that they feel um the
parties are actually going to stand by
those commitments and which one will be
most trusted
oh well j generally speaking leveling up
is a concept that that means different
things to different people but it's
certainly not something that has one
particular approval with
with the general public or in in the red
wall and we see that in the in the
polling that it's not the case that any
one party wins through in terms of in
terms of their solutions and really this
is a problem that the conservatives have
have made for themselves by committing
to this at the last general election and
then hoping that uh hoping that they
could uh they could come up with a
series of series of initiatives that
would convince those people in those
constituencies to either give them the
benefit of the doubt when it came to the
next election and allow them more time
to deal with the issue or uh that would
make a noticeable change and the
people's perceptions in those areas
would change but what we've seen in a
whole host of polling is that is the
moment people simply don't think that it
has made a difference to uh to them or
they think it's likely to make a
difference to her to them and this is a
and this is a problem for the
conservatives if they're too uh if
they're to pursue this as a as a policy
they may of course abandon it to abandon
it entirely when the new leader comes in
though i think that's unlikely but
whoever is in charge has to deal with
the fact that uh the dominance
particularly of london but also the
south more generally is something that
has lasted in this country for well over
two
two millennia and uh and addressing
history uh in uh in that respect is
quite difficult
and joe let's uh look at the final bit
of polling that we've got still from the
red wall and this is all about uh the
economy and this will be a terrible
viewing for conservatives apparently the
party of sound money and that they seem
to be behind to the labour party are on
their management of the economy to
people in the red wall
uh yeah and uh and the conservatives
have been behind on management of the
economy now for a number of months and
indeed it was this that uh
that at least helped to provide the
impetus for uh for boris johnson's uh
boyce johnson's removal because it has
never been the case that a party has
come from behind on leadership and come
from behind on economic management to
win the most seats of the general
election it's never happened in this
country and for months now the
conservatives have been behind on
economic competence
and they've been behind on leadership
and the question that the conservative
leadership candidates must face is do
they have answers that will that will
answer the key questions that people
have on the economy generally on
inflation on the cost of living because
at the moment the answers that uh that
have been put forward as part of the
leadership contest and as i say they're
appealing to a different group so it
might be different once they get into
downing street but so far those answers
failed to convince the general public
and if the predictions of energy price
rises that we've been hearing about over
the last few days are to come true and
we see that we see that bills
potentially rise by thousands of pounds
in 12 months the implications for that
are enormous there are reports this
morning that there could be a series of
rolling blackouts in this country over
the uh over the winter period because of
the because of the drain on drain on
energy if that happens then the chances
of the conservatives at least in the
short to medium term recovering their
reputation for economic competence the
chance of them moving ahead in those
figures seems very unlikely because as
each day goes past that narrative that
conservatives can't be trusted on the
economy simply becomes more and more
ingrained and as i say these results
have essentially not changed whether you
talk to the red wall whether you talk to
the general public these results have
not changed now for months
okay joe twyman from dad's ball
appreciate it thank you